hi I'm Hannah your friendly neighborhood
wine mom welcome to my couch it's been a
while we have a very special episode
today though BuzzFeed has finally
listened and they've come out with their
own line of custom wines it's called
warty wine you can customize the label
they have 3 different types you can
order so naturally I was their very
first customer and I just received mine
I've got a variety pack and I figured
let's just do a whole episode opening
them and tasting them so I couldn't do
this without my very special guests
obviously so everybody please welcome
Chris Webb fancy wine man extraordinaire
hey been a while it has yeah I'm just
wondering where the friendship bracelet
went that I made oh yeah I haven't even
opened like the box yet early so this is
gonna be really exciting oh ok this is
the red oh my gosh this is leave mom
alone red and the thing is you can pick
the background of the label to you and
like the design so we just went for like
an all black this is like a warning sign
almost this is a rosy and it's a wine
mom Rosa alright okay so this must be
the white this one is called living with
three boys and cleaning the bathroom I
almost don't want to drink it but we're
gonna drink it yeah we should dress okay
okay so we're gonna start off with
living with three boys and cleaning the
bathroom white okay Cheers yeah Cheers
okay
I'm not in my house you're slow okay
what is it tastes like what's very
floral like white peaches and apricots
what does that do least Pacific
three-team it kind of does the same
thing as this you know kind of have you
ever had wine like where you you first
open it and you're like us it doesn't
really taste like as bold as I remember
but you wait a little while like five 10
minutes and then all the sudden it
tastes different again I never wait so
what does it taste like what would I
drink this with this is a great
representation of of California whites
it's got a minerality it's got nice acid
it's got fruit flavors on the redness so
if you were gonna make your own custom
label what would yours say for this one
hmm
ooh that's a great question I would
probably say classic California classic
California this is a great
representation of just California whites
no it's it's it's really nice definitely
nicer than the label that was next wine
I called this one wine mom Rose a
because this is like the wine for me
okay so if you guys get this please why
mom on the label and send me a picture
because it will make my year it's
Italian Rose day it's from Tuscany it's
classy yeah
where's Tuscany Italy oh we're in Italy
the middle that's kind of right oh this
smells really good it smells like
watermelons it does first
it smells really nice okay watermelons
and like rose petals yeah yeah cheers
Cheers all right very sweet it's sweeter
than the white but I mean it's more like
it's fruity it's like strawberries
watermelon peaches it's like summer
fruit let's like a jolly rancher a wine
flavored Jolly Rancher yeah I'm sure the
winemaker likes his wind
crab doesn't Jolly Rancher singing it as
a compliment
ain't nothing wrong with a nice Jolly
Rancher total sidenote oh I read the
comments on the videos that you've been
in ok people like you well that's a like
like you that's good what's your deal
so like I'm married but I have some
really nice single friends what's like
your dream girl ok tell me everything I
can tell you something ok the other day
I was making macaroons ok chug we're on
the third and final wine
this is leave mom alone red you get this
thing when you have kids especially as a
mom you're like constantly touched yeah
nobody touched me for 10 minutes like
just don't touch me
this is what I don't have kids no it's
not a bad thing it's beautiful and it's
wonderful and I love it but don't don't
[ __ ] touch me you know leave me alone
ok alright that's good that's fine
that's ok we're tasting it right Cheers
whoo I like this that's really good I'm
really happy with this I usually don't
even like red wine but this is really
nice it's easy to drink about saddle
leather have you tasted saddle leather
no but I've smelled it it smells like
saddle up Oh what kind of date would you
drink this on which number date and
where would you be this could definitely
be a second date one second yeah oh you
don't get to go out much do you mm-hmm
can you tell
so what would you put on the label
second date red oh well I do hope you
can find someone very special you can
share this second date redwood why do I
keep doing this your best friend so
that's it I'm kind of sad that this was
over so soon I feel like this one by
very quickly Tennyson would order again
very pleased with the labels very
pleased with the taste yeah we had a
great time if you want to order your own
you can go to war dy
come and get your own custom label again
if you get the wine mom Rose I take a
picture and send it to me because I'd
love to see that special thanks to Chris
our fancy wine man for coming to taste
these with me so I didn't have to drink
alone on my couch if we want to find you
on the interwebs where can we find you
at Topher Webb on Twitter hear that
ladies that's where you can message him
wink wink nudge nudge til next time
[Music]
drinking